I would have biobacked be incorporated in my protocol so biobat is a infrared
heat source but that's really what a biobat is. They make all sorts of other
claims. I'm not against biobats. I think they're nice great heat sources but I
don't believe in a lot of the other claims that they make selling their
products. That's just my opinion but I not against biobats so they're good
infrared heat sources. We have other infrared heat packs on our store. A
biobat is typically a large one that you lay on. You use that. There's no harm in
doing that. There's no harm in using. You could use that in your protocol. You
could use it on your bed. That's totally acceptable. Can or should I drink raw
milk? No. That was raw milk better for a person than pasteurized milk. Well
sure it is. Pasteurized kills any of the you know positive good enzymes in it.
Of course raw milk you got to make sure that you're getting it from a good
clean source. So you should try to inspect the farm. You know we used to help
friends of ours milk their cows and we used to get raw milk from them. This
was years ago but they had a real clean bar. It's a please use yourself kept it
very clean and there was you know so we trusted the source of you know that
milk but we also we had no other people that we saw their barred it was
disgusting it was just horrible and there's no way I drink raw milk on it. Those
other people's barn so you do want to look at that. Secondly why should you be
drinking raw milk? Should you be drinking raw milk with the cancer diagnosis?
Typically no. Milk has other growth factors in it that could you know increase
the growth of cancer so the answers no. Should you be drinking eating raw cheese?
No, you should typically not be eating raw cheese as a cancer diagnosis. Now I
know that on a lot of you I have recommended no dairy so there's no dairy made
absolutely positively not one speck of dairy. Hey I've said this you know a thousand
times maybe a hundred times for sure that's not even exaggerating. That your diet is
your diet it's not a religion it's not something that you have to you know
steal all the joy from your life to keep it. Certainly eating butter is a whole
lot better than for you than a lot of the plant-based spreads and stuff so if
you're not consuming a ton of butter every day you could certainly continue to
use butter in an appropriate fashion instead of the plant-based
based spreads out there. There's just a lot of things that are good for you in the
bad oil. Certainly using olive oil certainly using coconut oil those are good
oils to use but I really don't see any real benefit for any cancer
pressure drinking milk of any kind whether it's raw or pasteurizing.